.
In this presentation I want to introduce you to the idea
Multidimensional equations
The word may seem fake, but all
Meaning is a phrase containing a set of variables or constants
Which are raised to non-zero forces
Perhaps this also seems complicated
So let me explain to you an example
If you want to give you x ^ 2 + 1, these are
Multilevel equation
In fact these are considered to be multi-border because they contain two sides
A pluralistic term is more general
Its content that you have several limits. Multiple word
Means many
These are multiple borders
If you want to say 4x ^ 3 - 2x ^ 2 + 7
This is a trilateral border
I have three borders here
Let me give you a precise meaning of what it is
Boundary is what is not
For example, if I have x ^ -1 / 2 + 1
This is not a polynomial
This does not mean you will never see it when
It deals with algebra or mathematics
But we will not call this polynomial because it contains
AS Sallab and Ksari
Or if you want to give you the expression y × square root
For y - y ^ 2
Again, this is not a polynomial, because it contains
The square root, which basically raises a number
For strength 1/2
If all the bases exist on the variables you must
Be nonzero
Again, neither of these is considered multi-boundary
Now, when we deal with multiplexers, you will
We get some terms
They are probably familiar to you or maybe not so familiar, so
I will explain it to you now
The first term is a polynomial degree
Multilevel degree
That is our highest rating
In the polynomial
For example, a polynomial is so
Multilevel Class III
Why?
There is no need to continue writing it
Why is it considered a multilevel class III?
Because the highest SS is in it
The phrase x ^ 3
From here we got a multi-border third-class
This is a multi-border second-order
This is a second-order phrase
Now there is a set of other terms, or words, that
Need to know about the polynomials, which are fixed words
As opposed to changing, I think you already know
There are changing phrases here
This is fixed
That's fixed
And then there is a last part until we explain
The properties of a polynomial is to understand transboundary coefficients
Let me write a five-level polynomial here
Maybe I'll type it unconventional
Here
I will not put it in the usual order
Let's assume that it is x ^ 2 - 5x + 7x ^ 5
- 5
Again, this is a multi-level V-limit
Why?
Because the highest IS on the variable here is 5
Here
This tells us it's a multi-level V-limit
Maybe you're saying, well, why do we care for that?
At least, for me, I care
To the point of polynomial because when the numbers grow
The higher pitch is what controls
On other phrases, they grow faster, or
Less quickly, depending on whether they are
The signal is positive or negative in front of it
But he will control everything else
It gives you the meaning of speed
Full gateway growth in case
If they contain a negative coefficient
Now I have used the word coefficient
what does that mean?
Factor
I used it before, when
I dealt with linear equations
Transactions are constants
Multiplied by changing expressions
For example, the coefficient of this phrase
Here is -5
You have to remember that we have -5, so consider
5-Entire Transaction
The coefficient of this expression is 7
There is no coefficient here; it's a constant phrase for
Then the coefficient x ^ 2 is 1
The coefficient is 1
It is not apparent
You assume it is 1 × x ^ 2
Now, the last thing I want to introduce to you is
The idea of ​​a typical form of a polynomial
The typical form of polynomial
Now, none of this will help you solve the polynomial
But when we talk about the solution of the polynomials
Maybe I use some of these terms, or that your teacher
Some of these terms may be used
So it's good to know what we're talking about
The typical form of polynomial is only
Put the phrases in order of rank
This is not the typical form
If you want to put this polynomial in the typical form
I will put this phrase first. If you type 7x ^ 5
Then what is the next smallest score?
Well, we have the phrase x ^ 2
We do not have the phrase x ^ 4 or
x ^ 3
So be + 1 - well, I do not have to
Type 1-- + x ^ 2
Then I have this phrase, -5x
Then the last phrase I have is -5
This is the typical form of polynomial where it exists
In descending order of grades
Now let's move on to solve a set of operations using polynomials
This toolkit will be very useful later
In algebra, or in the fields of mathematics
Let us simplify a set of polynomials
We have been exposed to this in previous presentations
But I think it will give you a better meaning, in particular
When we have phrases at higher degrees
So let's assume I want to get -2x ^ 2
+ 4x - 12
I will combine it to 7x + x ^ 2
Now the important thing to remember when you simplify
These polynomials are you will collect phrases
Which have the same variable degree
I will solve another example quickly as I have several
Variables exist in one case
But anyway, I have these brackets here, but they are
Actually do not do anything
If I have a quote put here, I will have to
Distribute the negative signal, but it does not exist now
If I can type this as -2x ^ 2 +
4x - 12 + 7x + x ^ 2
Now let's simplify it
Let us combine phrases of the same degree
When I say the same degree, it must be
It has the same variable as well
But in this example, we only have the variable x
So let's do the collection process
Let's see, I have the phrase x ^ 2 these, and I have the phrase x ^ 2 those
So I can bring them together
I have -2x ^ 2 - let me write them down
First, -2x ^ 2 + x ^ 2
Then let me extract x, 4x and 7x
This is 4x + 7x
Then finally, I have this hard
Here, IE-12
If I have -2 of something, I added 1 of the
The same thing, what do I get?
-2 + 1 = -1x ^ 2
I can only type -x ^ 2
But I wanted to make it clear to you that I am collecting
-2 to 1 here
Then I have 4x + 7x = 11x
Then finally I have a hard, -12
I end up with three borders
Multilevel Class II
The coefficient is here, ie the coefficient of the upper term
In the typical format - it is already typical -
Is -1
The coefficient here is 11
The hard is -12
Let us take another example of these examples
I think you understand the general idea
Now let me have a complex example
Let's assume that I have 2a ^ 2b - 3ab ^ 2 + 5a ^ 2
b ^ 2 - 2a ^ 2 b ^ 2 + 4a ^ 2 b
- 5b ^ 2
So here I have a negative sign, I have several variables
But let's solve it step by step
If the first thing we will do is
Distribution of negative signal
If this first part we can write it as follows 2a ^ 2 b -
3ab ^ 2 + 5a ^ 2 b ^ 2
Then we distribute the negative signal, or multiply
All these limits are B-1 because we have
Negative signal abroad
If -2a ^ 2 b ^ 2 - 4a ^ 2 b
And negative × negative = positive 5b ^ 2
Now we will combine similar phrases, if I have
The phrase 2a ^ 2 b ^ 2
Are there any phrases containing a ^ 2
b ^ 2?
Sorry, a ^ 2 b
I have to be careful here
Well, this is not ab ^ 2, no, a ^ 2 b ^ 2
Oh!
I have here a ^ 2 b
Let me write this down
I have 2a ^ 2 b - 4a ^ 2 b
These are the two terms
Let me move to orange
If I have here ab ^ 2
Now do I have other ab ^ 2 statements?
Terms ab ^ 2 Other
No, there are no other ab ^ 2 terms, so I will write it
-3ab ^ 2
Then let's see, I have the words a ^ 2 b ^ 2 here
Do I have any other one?
Well, yes sure, the following phrase is
The phrase a ^ 2 b ^ 2, so let me
Write it down
+ 5a ^ 2 b ^ 2 - 2a ^ 2
b ^ 2, right?
I wrote them
Then finally I have the last b ^ 2 phrase
+ 5b ^ 2
Now I can gather them
If the first set here is painted violet, two elements of
Something - 4 of this thing = -2 of
That thing
This equals -2a ^ 2 b
And then this phrase, will not be combined with
Anything, 3ab ^ 2
So we can combine these two phrases, if I have 5 elements of
Something - 2 of this, I will have 3 elements
Of this thing
+ 3a ^ 2 b ^ 2
Then finally I have that last phrase, which is + 5b ^ 2
We're done
We have simplified this polynomial
Here, by putting it in typical form, you can think of it
In different ways
The way you think best is
University degree of the term
Maybe we can put these first, but this
It's up to you
This is 3a ^ 2 b ^ 2
Then you can choose whether you want to put phrases
a ^ 2 b or ab ^ 2 first. 2a ^ 2 b
And then we have -3ab ^ 2
Then b ^ 2 here
+ 5b ^ 2
We're done
We have simplified this polynomial
What I want now is to solve a bunch of examples
Create multiple borders
In fact, the idea is to give you an idea
Because of the importance of polynomials, short representations
We will use it all the time, not just in algebra
But later in calculus, and in everything
So they are good things to see
But what I want to do in these four examples is to represent
Space each of these shapes using a polynomial
I will try to coordinate the colors as much as possible
So here, what is the space?
Well, the blue part here, its area
Is x × y
x x y
Then what is the space here?
Will be x x z
If + x × z
But we have two of them!
We have one area x x z, and then we have
The last area is x × z
I can collect xx z here
Or I can type, + 2 × (x × z)
Here's our multi-border space
The shape is here
Now let's find the space of the next figure
What is the space here?
Well, I have a × b
ab
This seems to be also a × b, if + ab
This seems to be also ab, if + ab
+ ab
I think it has been painted
oddly
Well, I will direct this c
Perhaps it is meant that this c
Because that is the information we need
Maybe they're telling us that this is the norm, ie
These, c
Because that will help us
But if we assume that this is also ab, it is
I will assume it for this show
Then we have another ab
We have this a
a × c
This is the space of this shape
It is clear that we can combine these four borders
This is 4ab and then we have + ac
This assumption was made and had a typo, where
That c has been given to us as a show
This box is here
We do not know if it's square, and that's only if it's a and c
Equal
Now let's move on to this
How do we find the space of this pink shape?
Well, we can take the entire rectangle, so that
Be 2xy, and then subtract space
These boxes
If each square is x x, x ^ 2
We have two of these boxes, then
The space will be - 2x ^ 2
Then finally, let's move on to this
This seems to be a dividing line
If the space of this point, of this space, is
a × b, which is equal to ab
Then the space here looks like ab too
If + ab
The space here is ab too
If the total area is 3ab
Anyway, I hope this offer has been explained to us
Boundaries
.